[Music]
you
you
you want to hear another story one with
a very fate of Pandora hangs in the
balance
if not too bad I'm telling you anyway
first there was the vault
an alien prison opened the mystical key
to the Warriors home the vault was just
a container of tentacles and
disappointment
they vanished into the wastelands
certain that the vault held no treasure
at all they were wrong box opening
triggered the growth of iridium a
priceless alien element soon the rare
and valuable mineral emerged all across
Pandora its appearance attracted many
including the Hyperion corporation they
came to Pandora to mine iridium and
bring order to the savage planet through
their excavations Hyperion uncovered
evidence of an even greater vault their
leader vowed to find it to use its power
to civilize the borderlands once and for
all
but Hyperion weren't the only ones
searching for the next Volks alien power
the call of danger and loot is not so
easily resisted certain warriors came to
Pandora in droves to uncover it
some would call them adventurers others
call them fools but I call them vault
hunters our story begins with them and
with a man named handsome Jack
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
just these y'all
with
the way
here
[Music]
this model hero
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's cute that y'all think you're the
heroes of this little adventure but
you're not welcome to Pandora kiddos
[Music]
great another deadbolt hunter handsome
Jack's been busy
[Music]